[Music]
oh I'm a dreamer
oh I think probably my wildest dream my
wildest dream like the priest flying
through space and all these planets were
hitting me then I flew over the Permian
Lane
what are they used to wait so I've
always wanted to like have sex and like
a build of light flowers like really
Paulo sunflowers down to like roses and
stuff and white sheets and then I've
always wanted to start raining a little
bit so I can I don't know kind of set
the mood a little more well that's my
loudest drink
oh I play to work for the NYPD oh I
would say to be a filmmaker so on the 57
horses
I really thought about that make the
most epic action film ever and have
everybody feel to be a star on Broadway
to be the Minister of Education in my
country
what can't you use Israel to travel the
world every day every day every day
superhero through for the rest of my
life to travel and just talk to people
and read books and eat great plant-based
foods
and those providers in front
um
the whale shark because all the people
are on the road everything
not arranged every person to meet every
story takes personality to be a big
factor in a big soccer team my wildest
dream is family like a big one I'd like
to have a big family and I think that's
the scariest part is knowing that it can
be really difficult and all the negative
stigma that comes along without being in
a relationship with another man
[Music]
run away to the Mediterranean and just
island hop the rest of my life to own an
animal rescue probably doing something I
like for the rest of my life so just
video games while this dream would be to
be a voice actor life for movie previews
er commercialism narrating things I'm
not everything I want to have my scars
in my name is I would survive I go to
the moon Oh to go skydiving toy to sail
around the world with a man that I love
maybe flying I think again literally
playing like a bird
totally that one I don't know that I
live in mark I'm planning the
environment or my family or
something out
to be an astronaut even though I know
they're going to happen probably an
astronaut
travelling separate country in the world
and sampling the food to have my own
business my own travel business with her
and plan events and trips well man
you're really close to me you know
supposed to intimate day oh it is - okay
what's your name I'm Kelsey where are
you from I was born in Georgia and
raised a little bit in Georgia and I
moved in Maryland so I claim both okay
okay how old are you I'm 25
what's your wildest dream my wildest
dream Joe I don't have wild dreams I
think I think I have hopes and wishes
okay the only one I want kids it's so
it's so funny because people dream about
like money and cars and stuff I don't I
just want to have a family and if you
can choose the questions that I would
ask people tomorrow Oh what would it be
Oh from the same
what's your biggest fear
[Music]